Speaker 1: OK. Let's go next to
Jess in Oregon. Jess, welcome.
Speaker 5: Hello, David, how are you?
So I'm just I'm just doing so wonderful,
I we call, I'm sorry, I called a few weeks
ago from Florida, from Gainesville, Florida,
right? And I've made my move. So now I'm here now.
Speaker 1: Are you in Oregon or Oregon?
Speaker 5: I have not I have been here about three
weeks and not heard one person call it Oregon,
Speaker 1: so you can't say for sure,
but it sounds like you're in Oregon.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think I think that's where
Eugene is, as in Oregon. Yeah, beautiful,
beautiful. So I was wondering, I would love to get
your take on if this is a good potential middle
ground to pro-life and pro pro-abortion rights.
Speaker 1: So we there's have you ever met a
pro-abortion person? I never have pro-abortion to
means you're going around trying to get people to
have abortions. I've never seen that right.
Speaker 5: I said, OK,
I should. I should. I should.
Speaker 1: Pro-Choice, pro-choice,
abortion rights.
Speaker 5: OK, particularly. OK, got it. So
if we're going, if we're talking about people who
are for abortion rights and people on the other
side who think that that is murdering babies, you
know, it's kind of hard to find a middle ground.
But see, I'm thinking of it like. Why do we keep
talking about that particular aspect of abortion
when there are a lot of other aspects around this
that I think we can agree on, like young mothers
who, you know, maybe would rather have
abortion if they can't get abortion, then
you know, I'd add, like federal funding for
young mothers to these bills, to these bills that
that restrict abortion rights.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Yeah. One
of the things we've talked about many times
is you can't both say you should be forced
to have a kid and then not provide any
support for the kid to people who are not
financially in a good position to have a kid.
Speaker 5: Absolutely
right. Because, yeah, you know, if
the if the other solution is get
rid of the kid before it's born and you
can't do that, OK, well, then help me
out if I'm forced to have a kid, you know?
Speaker 1: Yeah, this is the broader. This
is the broader hypocrisy of an insane amount of
concern for, you know, clumps of cells for weeks
into a pregnancy and then total disregard
for babies after they're born. I mean that
that's a long term hypocrisy we've seen.
Speaker 5: But see, instead of like I know you
and I and many other people who share that
same view, we kind of get stuck on like,
Oh, you pro-life people are being so hypocritical
instead of be like pro-life people. What
about this idea? Do you agree with this?
Speaker 1: Sure. No, it should be proposed.
Absolutely. The problem is most in most cases,
if Democrats try to bring that up during a debate
over abortion. Republicans would say that's not
this bill. If you want to propose a different
bill, propose it. But right now we're talking
about this bill so that that's the political
strategy question you have to deal with.
Speaker 5: Really? Yeah. So I think that
that's a different situation really well.
Speaker 1: They would say it's not part
of Republicans would say that's just not part of
our bill. If you want to propose that propose it,
but you've got to make your own bill.
Speaker 5: Aha! Because because restricting
abortion isn't a direct
cause to that effect. Oh, of
Speaker 1: course you're right about you're
not wrong that it's of course related.
OK. All right. Just thank you for the call. I
appreciate it. What I'm saying is the Republicans
wouldn't allow it into their bill. They would
say, Here's what we want to do about abortion.
Here's what's right to do about abortion. If
you have other ideas that you want to propose,
by all means, go ahead and propose them. Let's
take a very quick break. If you're holding,
just keep holding because we're going
right back to the phones in a moment.